voici un chapitre de l'histoire
éternelle des efforts de l'homme pour
profiter de l'énergie détenu par ce
monde qui nous entoure
à
[Musique]
l'homme a naturellement utiliser
l'énergie du soleil pour les plantes et
les animaux
nous nous retirons notre subsistance
[Musique]
avec le feu l'homme pour la première
fois analyse à une source d'énergie afin
de pouvoir la contrôler
il libéra l'énergie contenue dans le
charbon il découvrit d'immenses nappes
de pétrole et de gaz naturel qui pouvait
être brûlé en chaleur et en lumière
[Musique]
il convertit la chaleur du charbon du
pétrole et du gaz en énergie électrique
on
il canalise à la houille blanche pour
augmenter sa production d'électricité
cette électricité qui révolutionne son
mode de vie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui se lève l'aube d'un nouvel
âge née de la découverte et de
l'utilisation de la plus puissante
source d'énergie de l'histoire du monde
l'énergie qui peut être dégagés à partir
de l'atome
non contrôlée cette puissante source
d'énergie est aussi la plus destructive
mais en totale coopération
internationale toutes les nations
souhaite justement la contrôler afin de
fournir de l'énergie pour le bien de
l'homme pour la prospérité du monde
futures un monde qui ne connaîtraient
plus la famine les maladies
comment cette puissance de l'atome
peut-elle améliorer ainsi le sort de
l'humanité tout entière
d'une part elle peut fournir de
l'énergie électrique aux états unis des
savants conçu et réalisé la première
centrale électronucléaire du monde
aujourd'hui
cette énergie est généralement plus
coûteuse que celle obtenue à partir
d'autres sources
mais cette technique plus développés
sera très prochainement rentable et tout
d'abord dans les régions du monde où les
combustibles ordinaires sont rares et
dont les prix de transport sont élevés
en juillet 1955 pour la première fois
dans l'histoire la tombe procure à
l'énergie permettant d'éclairer une
ville
harpo petite cité de l'ouest des états
unis fut entièrement éclairé par de
l'électricité venant d'une centrale
électronucléaire leur monde entier
aujourd'hui nombreux sont les pays qui
travaillent à rendre effective cette
utilisation de l'atome
ainsi en france l'une des plus
importantes centrales électronucléaires
d'europe est pratiquement terminé
mais voici un autre domaine dans lequel
déjà l'énergie nucléaire aen vrai pour
le bien de l'homme
[Musique]
grâce à des expériences de rayonnement
de meilleures phrases de plantes se
développent des graines ont un rendement
de production à bon temps d'autres moins
certaines donnent des plantes résistant
aux maladies
d'autres produisent des plantes
facilement attaquable les agronomes et
les avants ont fait de grands progrès
dans la production de plants avant
demain abondant et de haute résistance à
la maladie mais les moyens employés sont
longs et fastidieux
il fallut un quart de siècle
d'expérience difficile pour produire le
maïs hybride qui double presque
maintenant le rendement d'une récolte
par mètre carré
aujourd'hui des expériences ont confirmé
le fait que la radiation atomique peut
produire les variétés héréditaire
recherché par les savants et elle les
produira en un temps étonnamment moindre
que la nature
mais c'est faire pousser des plantes
résistantes n'est qu'une partie du
problème
il faut aussi préserver les produits
alimentaires les produits de la ferme
par exemple risquent d'être abîmés
pendant leur transport ou leur
magasinage
lors d'un long voyage ou d'un long
stockage dans des lieux où la
réfrigération est difficile ou
impossible
les produits alimentaires deviennent
impropres à la consommation atteint de
microbes détruits par les insectes ou
des fléaux de toutes sortes
sous la direction du gouvernement des
états unis des centaines d'expérience
sur divers produits alimentaires sont
actuellement en cour à chicago
l'institut des aliments et de leurs
contenants coordonne ce programme
expérimental
[Musique]
ici un technicien prépare des boîtes de
produits alimentaires pour qu'elle soit
irradiés ou laboratoire argonne de
chicago dépendant de la commission à
l'énergie atomique
ces études sont avancées dans beaucoup
de régions des volontaires gouttes les
aliments pour examiner les réactions
positives ou négatives aux radiations
on juge aussi les effets de ses rayons
sur le goût des différents aliments
on a déjà pu déterminer que certaines
sortes de viandes réagissent
favorablement aux radiations
au contraire du lait et de ses dérivés
les réactions des légumes et des fruits
sont très variables
l'irradiation promet des progrès dans le
domaine de la prévention contre les
maladies
la tri qui n'osent par exemple maladie
souvent fatales due à l'ingestion des
viandes de porc infecté serait
considérablement réduite
si toute la viande de porc pouvaient
être traitées les insectes comme les
charançons serait presque totalement
éliminés si des sacs imperméable à l'air
comme ceux ci étaient exposés aux
radiations
comparer la pomme de terre irradiée à
celle qui a tout gernez les pommes de
terre acide traitées peuvent être
conservées sans un magazine mensuel sial
jusqu'à deux ans les biologistes de tous
les pays ont trouvé que les
radio-isotopes ouvrent des champs
d'étude qui autrefois semble est un
domaine de recherche presque
impénétrable
depuis la création humaine
la maladie a toujours été notre grande
ennemie fléau et épidémies des six
maires des populations entières
aujourd'hui sur la plus grande partie du
globe la science médicale arrête ou
limite ces fléaux
immense d'efforts ont été faits contre
la tuberculose et la paralysie infantile
mais la médecine se trouve encore face à
des énigmes dont la plus tragique
demeure celle du cancer ici à l'hôpital
naval de bethesda dans le maryland des
isotopes de divers éléments sont
utilisés par les laboratoires pour des
essais diagnostiques et thérapeutiques
du cancer les radio isotopes offre une
source bon marché de rayons gamma
utilisé pour le traitement du cancer
il est maintenant possible d'amener une
source de ses rayons en étroit contact
avec les tissus cancéreux sans poser de
dommages de radiation sensible aux
tissus sains des examens les plus
récents du cancer est possible grâce à
ce nouveau compteur de radiation le
patient à qui l'on a inoculé des doses
minimes de liquide radioactif est placé
sur une table le compteur se déplace au
dessus de sa tête différenciant
graphiquement les tissus cancéreux des
tissus sains
peut-être à la longue la plus grande
contribution de l'atome se rappelle bd
l'homme à obtenir une meilleure
connaissance de la vie elle-même
d'importantes études sont rendues
possibles dans le domaine de la
photosynthèse
le mystérieux processus par lequel les
plantes qui nourrissent l'homme et les
animaux utilisent le dioxyde de carbone
et l'eau pour fabriquer le sucre la mito
et les graisses la photosynthèse est
probablement le problème biologique le
plus important sans elle il n'y aurait
pas de manifestations de la vie sur la
terre comme nous les connaissons
personne ne sait quand ce mystère sera
résolu
personne ne peut prédire quand on
obtiendra une percée importante ce qui
veut dire pour les savants une
découverte qui permettrait la production
d'une quantité illimitée de produits
alimentaires à partir d'éléments simples
libérant à jamais l'homme de la menace
de la frappe
l'homme a toujours espéré et vécu avec
la perspective d'un lendemain qui serait
meilleur aujourd'hui
pour cela il a recherché des sources
d'énergie trouver le feu et les
carburants et enfin la force et la
puissance contenue dans l'atome
cette énergie atomique qui promet de
meilleurs landes
aux peuples du monde
[Musique]